mike says here so if you take matters
read apologies for absence of these are
already longer descending there are
other side cottages thank you sorry
minutes to the meeting on the third
December is it your wish I saw them as a
true record will it include declarations
of interest if there are any that come
up during the meeting please declare up
at that point message refer to the
executive and reports from other
committees there are none so we start
please with item 6 which is the
performance report so here we are thank
you right so I've gotta sleep pages by
name starting at page 3 anybody on
Frasier oh yes if I may please okay and
the item b li 0 1 0 because to business
rates I'd be interested to know how many
companies have approached us because
i've had problems in making the right
payments and how many companies would be
able to help and how much is being
deferred crossed over k over time have
to come back to
okay any of us on that page I mean
character on the other version this is
in point what's in there which is no
difference but I just think we need to
know the comments on me the first one is
armed council tax yeah there's so much
it into January will it same as genuine
last year recent of court time for 41
days in here you know they'll notice the
collection rate is two percent up on the
BB 0 1 0 so that's a break in your
exhalation do you have another question
is yes at home you've got two rapes for
charities and we give them a discount on
balloon there's a mandatory eighty
percent relief which we have to give
them then they can apply for twenty
percent discretionary relief and
portfolio holder signs off on those now
are those charities that we support in
that way do we make it known that that
we are supporting them in giving than
that not by individual we report in the
annual report of how much support we've
given is only about 23,000 pounds a year
no just wondering is that something we
should be adding to what work so how was
supporting their charities chickens it
God's law by individual charity or just
a total value I think it'd be
interesting by interesting individual
charities to have so that we have was
supporting just to say is that a
statutory theme the mandatory is the
discretionary absorptive obviously not
the discretionary birds as far as that's
concerned abuse only registered
charities yes yeah do we check the
registration I know that sounds a funny
thing to say but we do have a a charity
and rocks food that says registered
across his window that his name play and
he isn't I can help you check
okay we wish I do due diligence and
copies of account you supposed to be the
council they've submitted to the charity
commercial we have okay any more on that
one page for this point for these kind
of coming back if you mix 16.5 but again
as far as the fourth one is concerned we
end up how much we're actually writing
off yes and unfortunately we're now
responsible for always the rifles and it
looks like coming you're saying they're
focusing at the total day right yeah
that's something benefits something 600
cooks yeah in the end financial
management report has the total okay
special everybody else from that off
right h6 age seven
I notice that the fingers are still not
consistent relating the Pope Clement
hall and rainy leisure presumably that's
because they've got usage formulator but
if you go if you actually solve that yet
oh I'll double check yeah I could you
need to get those who is right going
forward but page eight oh yes of course
yeah wonders I've seen this yes they
would press ok so you've got updates
there on page eight this is in tonnage
reporting for recycling so originally
slightly increased over the year which i
think is it something that's happening
across all authorities and falling the
toes recycled
the season friend yeah okay okay pays
nine gems or just coming I have some
more information about sub recycle yet
pulse please go ahead and this is a
email received today about same
recycling and if you remember some few
months ago I did give a con warning
about the possibility of Armageddon
business with our recycling and playing
my copy one part of the actual process
the Mexica taking place and bitters in
terms of green general items and various
operations previously we were receiving
10 pound a tongue for episode at nine
thousand tons per year so easy between
this now this is for material again
keeping job it now looks as though we
will not be getting the 10-pound the
time he'll be lucky if we get 0 4 ton
and it could actually start costing us
to get a little bit crispier we could
because they're why is the fiction I'm
just preparing the moment I wonder if
they should be pnc it was just it's not
done this down here okay I know it isn't
I'm aware that Keith oh yes it does no
Munchak uppercut Jesus Jemaine companies
no not like the okay I've been
privileged to see this so I don't do
know there's company companies names in
there so if you can avoid that we don't
bring other names side you said another
one just the other point is that we're
still to meet I think two companies
there is another country of a meeting or
friday but there have been some they've
already met and the news from name is
not good so I'm just kind of giving a
pretty warning no more on friday but
we'll have a chance to falter the
executive until next
okay so just be on the safe side it
looks as though we may not get as much
money coming in from the recycling who
thought drinking excited if any and I
had already taken the income out of the
budget item 9 I mean the only thing I
said is I don't like these words hi only
unacceptable levels of litter I'm told
that's a national measure so there's not
much you can say about that that in
there you are item 10 yeah I'm gonna be
very this because it the finger looks as
though it's going up it says the rolling
everything just at the end of the
quarter there were fewer households in
temporary accommodations so not quite
sure where that sits I'm sure when I
believe that there are 12 12 households
in bed and breakfast at this exact
moment in time it says here in
households in temperate our nation
including Ben breakfast compared to the
previous court owned and chairman sorry
i'm just kickin and bit we're in the air
and there are 32 households at this
exact moment in time in temporary
comedies I it's actually better than the
survivors yeah and of course these
figures do fluctuate inevitably but
that's on a downward trend at the moment
it's just that if you look at the job is
going up that's the thing which you know
and quite understand where they were ok
so there's good news but anybody else on
10 11 please thank you all right so
there's been an update to not to number
11 their 60 yeah see ya tell me the
night weeks yeah right what anybody on
the 11 or 12 13 14 and 15 she's in
update on LP 1619 which is the first one
no job seekers
proving performance on that one well so
members no reports thank you next one
will be item seven right I mean I won't
go through this I'll just ask me mr.
comment if I might they want to pick up
his face Thank You chairman Pao
unfortunately this is not much better
than last consecutive meetings before we
serve items that have got end date or
time completion dates people plates of
the people firms how can you actually
kind of fun for progress or something
that has no ending the other thing is I
mean we've got certain items here which
should be finished in in march this year
which is 14 weeks at most and they are
under support just about twenty percent
complete that's not what words do it's
always and some of these so I still
think these reports are basically don't
worth the paper they're written on okay
well I think under the new setup of the
council has I mean many of these reports
will change radically except and I think
you made your point extremely well the
last time these are saying and some of
these will change and of the way the
methodology in the way they done trying
to work so hopefully if you have
comments on that was you can bring them
forward one I mean it [ __ ] Sharon
played on page two corporate plan
project prepare and a doctor community
infrastructure with every charging
scheme total patient they December 2015
it's taking down there two years I mean
you know we we need to kind of push that
one forward such rehearsals a lot of
money the one below it development and
development to live an approach Valley
living landscapes that's got 45 weeks to
do that's about ten percent complete so
there's not a lot of a saloon so if I
you know some of these I doubted the
targets are not correct or would be very
slowly progressing
this was done thank you hey I'm home
page them point eight reduce
homelessness and I asked Sean into it
just give us an update on the nine mile
stones because very your mind and the
target resolution day is march to their
projects day koj my name nigeria
pinterest programming tata motors mr.
Cho Cho so this is the one that has got
the clotting corporate plan projects is
our life oh very well here he's a
marriage is homelessness there's nine
milestones sure and well as you wrote
hence the week we have we have made some
typical progress towards I actually
achieving those milestones and some of
the work done done there are some
significant progress in relation to some
initiatives around working with
landlords and so on in order to reduce
the likelihood of homelessness occurring
so i think that is that thats as March
2016 actually that i said i like that
completion date that we are making
substantial progress as you owe you and
and will continue to do so and thank you
did you want to touch on a couple of the
am positive outcomes which were
highlighted our last meeting this from
executive and about the deposits being
paid up from which works our more
economical to help some of the families
who need to move
as opposed to a better breakfast yeah I
mean I sort of i hope that's what what
what one initiative that we are looking
at them clearly there are on occasion
they're not able to afford a deposit to
actually move me to rented accommodation
so you know cognizant of the fact that
we're paying area from bed and breakfast
it seemed to make sense to actually
cover the deposit to allow those people
to move into into into rented
accommodation where we can find a
landlord who's using able to to or
willing to accept you know almost almost
family so that that's a way of reducing
our exposure to either to ongoing bed
and breakfast costs for a relatively a
relatively modest sum and allows us
people can move into into a better
situation so one of the initiatives i'm
not sure what what we're watching to
paper you're reading young from cancer
cell phones you can probably unpack some
of that was from memory and the other
room thing on that report is it should
be march two thousand of his station I
would do sausage soup urs 2015 that's
why I was dreaming okay thank you
alright got canceled all the answers to
Tokyo Hudson police oh thank you I'm
grateful to cancel the first brings to
page eight it's the first item landing
page development and the rdc empty hand
strategy clogged completion date
december two thousand fourteen thirty
percent complete it's got a green status
I thought that would have been a
definite red mist is best by date then
terminate the intercom strategy that was
what was in draft by that December to
this and for what he did but you know we
have
we have we're and we're in discussion to
to actually finalize the the detail of
the strategy into its final form ensue
I've been i think i just described for
that but you say I say the completion
date was at the same time that was bleep
relational that was before any part of
the project I think we meet when we made
to miss the connection I think the
converse of that is it's warm 30 was it
done all this little bit hopefully it
won't anyone right there's a debtor
please write with reference to the empty
house strategy so which pay you that's
all based on came ate and you're right
no games overview that is all but done
now I think if you want to comment on
lecture yes update chairman that was
about me just to ever that was a point
of a service i was making it is it is
all he was it wasn't it wasn't it in the
draft format by the 7 2014 fifa decision
is just finalizing the officers have
been rather are in is unfortunate to
themselves by indicating that it's only
twenty-five or thirty percent i think
that sir and the torres you be like
Jenna I with jealousy 95 mistake if and
the tourism strategy and we've actually
got a tourism seminar tomorrow that's
going so where's the two is directly
under the empty hands for thanks HT I
that's got odd got like a few properties
of the Jews I versus on for hours yeah
oh no it's page 10 pitch ah physic
disappeared on human into shops I me
then you sure oh I do apologize imagine
wearing gym in hockey to take both those
strategies are virtually very
synergistic a few tonight well actually
I thought she doesn't press the empty
shots one is an Amber Rose empty homes
bomb which is further defined is that
she'd as a green so it can't even
conquer blood cell phone before so once
again that's more fuel to my father last
pump as I've already mentioned i think
when our new strategy counsel is in
place and has had a chance to bid it
these reports or and all take on a
different complexion anymore more
noteworthy i suggest um comments please
that if i make with respect to this
deposit that the counts were like
there's a page to a landlord i think we
shouldn't give it too much credence i
don't have a problem with paying it but
the purpose of a deposit to a landlord
is to encourage the landlord to give him
some reassurance that the tenant will
take care of his property if he's aware
that the council or any one other
organization is finding it that
reassurance is taken away it's not a
deposit which will ensure that the
property is repaired if the tenant
destroys it or damages in any way
although that's potentially what it's
for on the face of it the reality is a
landlord would take the view the
majority that I know anyway it will take
the view that if a tenant has put up
their own deposit then they are likely
to take more care of the property
well I was at the gym if I minute I me I
mean I understand the point and clearly
this is a cooperative process what we're
seeking to do is work with landlords and
landlords will be aware of the of the
arrangements so I mean one of the
challenges is to is is to persuade
private landlords to take homeless
families it's not an easy and easy tasks
many of them new shy away from that for
all variety of reasons and and in the
market that we have at the moment you
know that's of challenges of attitude to
this situation as well because they
amount of money that homeless families
get towards rent is often significantly
less than the that the market rent and
it so there are a whole series of
challenges but you know our what we've
been seeking to do is to try and engage
and work with with with landlords and
make some progress and then those two
things here it saves money than the bed
and breakfast option but most
importantly it serves our residents
better these are families are more
settled only if the landlord with
respect will accept concept that is the
council paying the deposit does that
give the landlord reassurance and
therefore does the property come
available anyway I have to say Steve and
working to build up I think it would be
more effective if somehow the council
could guarantee to undertake or to
arrange to undertake subsequent repairs
if they were needed if the if the
particular tentacles the problem I think
you'll find it much better as it's a
concept that used to be bye-bye'd held
by Al Ahly Council that they would
essentially take the property and hand
it back in its original pristine
condition and I think that would have
far more effect than just pan and pot
but substantially could cost us about
yeah and I think that's the risk because
we have already child that before I had
thought family I would have housing
association where landlords would give
the property to rupture counseling
association to take them three years how
much dead take after we get to it
practically zero and that's for sure you
will find it very difficult to find
landlords without that reassurance to
come forward with their property need to
get Tim the point the point is
interested it seems simply very
difficult to find landlords results out
there and who really said he called a
wrong and what he eats also the cost of
rental nowadays okay in like you know it
actually it's on the same subject and I
thought actually because the Hudson was
going to touch on that but it was always
seeking to recover that deposit
eventually is this something that we
will seek to do from these people that
weary housing or is it just added you
know from the tenant could partly
deposits now with the landlord yes
annuities but surely work the whole
premise is that the actual tenant
couldn't afford the deposit that was the
premise and that we are actually giving
that deposit so surely is there not a
case that at some time there should be
some form of recovery from the tenant
for that deposit which they couldn't
initially reform we can we do time we
have
deposits but we do end up writing off a
few where it's just impossible to buy
the other hand the income so to repay do
you think anybody doesn't learn home
loads quickly works on that bit
emotional separators yes but you'll find
sometimes in our books will show it's a
grant because we're now we're going to
write you off at some point in the
future and it's better stated earlier
and then still be cheaper the breakfast
that's the whole premise investment but
having said that when we do this do we
have an arrangement with the landlord
whether that it was it whatever's left
of it obviously don't know what
condition is going to be as she comes
back to us rather than the tendons pens
on the arrangement I mean that's really
your only get at that actually yeah yes
it's two aspects I mean one is you know
you know do you get a venturi the tenant
to sponsor the actual deposit over a
period of time whatever and the other
one is a boost if the tenant leaves that
particular property then that you know
we don't want them if you like statue or
being being able to have access to the
original deposit which is the normal
thing you do if you were inching a
property that we played it as an
organization so it should come back to
us sorry judge did you want to come in I
just want to search a member please
remember these
mythology to time and it emphasizes even
more the need for our portable housing
can I just ask is it a physical payment
or do we just give the guarantee that we
will pay we'd make change me to get a
physical thing okay thank you any more
comments on that any more comments on
this report place and there was no item
ticker was its theater 77 loose track of
these things all right so now item 8
which is the call to report the license
we noted there did you want to say
anything um there were a couple of
questions that arose from people have a
having lock detect the the first one was
was a point through the top of 8.3 as I
agenda papers unallocated receipts oh
yeah and Yvonne informs me that it will
actually possible to allocate those
receipts to appropriate car parks for us
so hopefully yeah that that the medium
done I know there was one known i found
i think is quite well on in the report
might even last page actually i think it
was there was the question about the
grammys well where were they oh yes and
the voluntary sector grant they come on
economic development is i think i've
received an email once about the 13
and there was a final one somewhere
about it lambertus someone touches as 23
and a half thousand pounds in the
capital program its fur mich knees farm
boots for agent fees for negotiations
nothing's been spent so far well I had
varlon page 24 the top of the page honda
tom knows 24 or he's tipped on those 24
alarm not during that point why argue
it's 8 24 or top notes 24.com because it
works just as well because you've got
their installation sorry always Parish
Council providing 20,000 manual planning
to the region of escape will brown polka
newton which is very good at than them
I'm sure that commie Roy the amount no
the intention hopefully she put up a new
different areas it's got much funding
either so booting the volume 20 thousand
like hampers no hull breach was hangover
for the item just above it or whatever
but Julius can you do stop I was every
warning well oh that was actually do all
over it hey listen to use the game enemy
diria okay anybody else want to come on
quit high school plays yet thank you
page eight or eight point four which
ever since you're using 52 4.3 the main
areas are spend 2014-15 the fudge the
fleet vehicles and real things and
collectively
negotiation referees contract if we cut
that down from 120 to 1055 so this guy
actually a major ice must have any week
about yearly spend that we have yes this
comes the cat that's capital program it
compares it to the appt the current
approved program so that reduction or
going two counts on next week thank you
Oh gets a walk first and it gets a look
at school thank you um just going back
to page 3 line point three on the
unallocated receipts all right
electronic payment yes so the wave on
pay and the credit card nature's come to
us in a lump design up high by fund as
well yes so there's there's gonna be
officer time and allocating a Catholic
school um page eight point 11 the bottom
thing on their emergency planning nice
budget includes provision for an
additional emergency on call officer
this post is yet to be recruited to I'm
glad to hear that because aren't we
making all our new IDs on call intern so
why do we need another 67,000 spent on
somebody to do it I don't know what
you're doing with you I think it's a I
don't think it's an additional emerges
in on corpse if there's no additional
person says addition of here this
additional to what was off in mind with
this an existing officer the too much
what did you check the worst part time
this is amazing
sorry Lisa talk to that someone means
he's going sorry sorry they get
additional Lance being on call and
that's all it is it means of one versus
a few dedicated to it so that's the
additional officer at the moment they've
got a couple never had a third one it
was actually on called man so when the
AG's because the encore person is the
one who's actually parent in the carpet
as a flood for example they're actually
out there on the field that the Aedes
will will be the people that will phone
it before are there additional
assistance or to talk something through
or agree a payment so you're telling me
we've got three of these we have two of
the moment think it is and if I those
holiday we've got to put out at one so
we need additional one to give us a
digital color in case there's sickness
people holidays or anything else when
somebody goes off it's just basically an
application allows they get for being on
call just basically six the ceiling fans
no it's not 67 that's what I said
because what it shouldn't be that much
because it's just a basic allowance it's
not on a new post well but is it where
it says here it says revised budget 73
end of year for past six to seven two
six nine so much please tell me what the
heck it is shouldn't they should just
make sure that actually the other person
it that's the cross center so it's all
the costs associated with providing the
emergency planning service so the
additional cost for the on-call officers
and I thought we had more than three is
about twenty-one twenty-two thousand
pounds which is part of that cost and it
also includes the salary costs for the
emergency planning officer jeff stays
citizen
if I'm a chairman we'll listen get
confused with thinking too far ahead to
what we're going to do this is third
quarter of where we are now what then
what's going on now so that there is the
bullpen normally of how some costs are
going to go forward with the changes
that with the regard perhaps the word it
should be rewritten because it doesn't
realize this forgive me jill but i'm not
denied everything you said but it does
they includes provision so it's not hold
this is something the point that it
doesn't say to be this is yet to be
recruited to you yeah but it's not for
the whole post isn't that's the thing so
okay miss Hudson place can we slip back
to page four on boat and just for my
education please the write-offs on
paragraph 3.5 the last item housing 8624
it is is that that might that will
include event profits I found it linked
to oh what a nice time and risk this
reflects me love hello jailhouse mod I'm
sure it would then I'm sure what
New York thinking is please I think as a
general comment as you as you go through
there are along variances with brackets
around them which are potential savings
and forecasts and I'm sort of a sample
per contra gargoyle I do think it is
something to give really feel reasonably
pleased about that there is a lot of
savings got happening there within a
fairly tight tight situation but if it
must go on record that where we've had
staff vacancies that have created some
of these savings it does mean that a
good number of our existing staff have
been picking up a few extra
responsibilities workin in a little
extra hard and covering but the result
is we've saved we save some money and
it's our residents money they're worth
one yeah right I'm really other comments
please but it's three license to note no
car near India forecasts so the current
financial performance as shown in
pendeks to and equal to sri captain
monitor at all that the world really
matters thank you see all these